de père hubert champenois recteur
justement de la cathédrale de nantes
bonsoir a perdu vers champenois merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france ce soir ce qui vous anime c'est
la tristesse et l'émotion est à la fois
les deux bien sûr tristesse et émotion
parce que je suis prête depuis 51 ans et
j'ai connu le le précédent incendie le
28 janvier 1972 à la cathédrale
aude où j'étais passé la journée
justement dans ce deuxième incendie un
de la cathédrale cette fois-ci non pas
sur la toiture de la cathédrale mais sur
ce à partir de là de l'armoire
électrique entre autres un peu serré et
trois feux 1 qui ont détruit le grand
orgue à 10000 le le buffet du l'ordre de
coeur et puis à bi média c'est aussi là
tout ce qui est un tableau classé au
dessus de l'armoire électrique
donc c'est une désolation qui a marqué
cette journée pour les nantais auquel la
cathédrale nous sommes tous prêts liés
avec la cathédrale qui fait partie du
patrimoine religieux de nord permettant
fait partie de l'histoire de nantes avec
les ducs de bretagne
les petits vous rendre sur place bien
sûr c'est en allant chercher mon pape ce
matin à 7h45 que quelqu'un venu en
courant me dire la cathédrale brûle
effectivement je immédiatement je me
suis rendu compte que des grandes
flammes sortaient de la rosa ce qui est
juste derrière le grand orgue et les
pompiers étaient déjà arrivés parce que
des des habitants de la place
saint-pierre avait remarqué quelqu'un
quelques nos maris deux côtés du douteux
du parti la cathédrale
qu'est ce qui a été endommagé
dans le 100 m demain à boma j'ai d'abord
les des pompiers ont fait un travail de
liberty remarquable et efficace puisque
malheureusement il y des gros dégâts
mais ça aurait pu être différent et par
rapport à avant 1972 vont pas oublier
que les nacelles ça n'existait pas les
portables ce n'existait pas et bien que
la cathédrale a commencé à brûler le
vendredi à midi jusqu'au dimanche dans
la nuit tandis que le graves événements
d'aujourd'hui au fait que le ce a pu
être maîtrisé trois quatre heures voilà
où il n'enquête inquiété
vestas il enquête ouverte mais d'abord
il faut qu'ils regardent et d analyser
c'est le travail de la police judiciaire
nous nous voyons les conséquences de cet
incendie qui sort qui vont priver les
feux les chrétiens d'eux mêmes mais
aussi des veut dire tout ce qui y
rendent dans la cathédrale
d'autant qu'on était une période de de
tourisme et bon nombre de touristes
surtout de français cette année et
autres années il y avait beaucoup
d'étrangers m
en visite passant par la visite est là
la cathédrale alors une enquête pour
incendie volontaire a été ouverte il
faut bien sûr rester prudent 1 mais ont
dénoncé ces images à nantes elle
rappelle d'autres images un an et demi
après un incendie de notre dame de paris
cyrielle vous évoque quoi la fragilité
de beaucoup de choses parce qu'il ya des
problèmes de sécurité
l'épreuve est aussi d'entretien régulier
et s'était déjà fait à 90 par rapport à
l'électricité
on venait de me le dire la la drac à
tout le patrimoine venait de refaire
toute électricité du coeur je veux dire
de et de vue du coût de l'intérieur de
la cathédrale
donc il y avait un suivi régulier puis
régulier régulièrement et du vin on se
retrouve avec les pompiers avec avec les
responsables du patrimoine pour faire le
point sur la sécurité voyez là les
travaux continuent l1 qui sont faits par
l'étang gelé dire pour l'entretien des
cathédrales de france
d'autant que l'évènement de notre dame
de paris a donné de lire à stimuler un
petit peu davantage les l'état pour être
encore plus attentif comme ils le sont
déjà
un panty xala à la vie de les dire des
cathédrales de leur donner d'arbres
maintenant il ya le premier ministre qui
s'est déplacé sur place avec d'autres
ministre un ministre de la culture
notamment roselyne bachelot vous vous
dites qu'on en clis suffisamment assez
pour protéger notre patrimoine en france
je dis pas qu'on a fait on n'en fait
jamais assez et te dire que
régulièrement on se retrouve pour faire
le point quant à l'attentât à la
sécurité avec les pompiers
quant à la sécurité avec la police la
gendarmerie etc
j'en suis témoin puisque le site au
service de la cathédrale depuis sept ans
des dons depuis sept ans des rencontres
de gears 2 lors du patrimoine religieux
de la cathédrale se vident et se vivent
plutôt de plus en plus merci beaucoup à
vous par hubert champenois je rappelle
que vous êtes le recteur de la
cathédrale de laon bokura je vous
remercie